is Douglas Murray once again on what you
have to do with these people who are who
are openly calling for genocide they are
fine with terrorist attacks and they are
brazenly expressing that on the Streets
of London I came back to London and I
hear the residue of the people outside
the Israeli Embassy these people were
not protesting against Israeli
countermeasures they hadn't even had any
counter measures they were protesting
because Jews by the hundreds had been
slaughtered in Israel and they wanted to
wound us more I've written in The
Spectator tomorrow a demand on the Prime
Minister and the Home Secretary that
supporters of Hamas in the UK must be
treated in exactly the same way as
supporters of Isis were if you stand in
Britain with a Hamas flag you should not
be allowed to be free in Britain you
should be arrested have your citizenship
withdrawn your passport withdrawn you
should be deported you should be sent to
the Gaza and try your luck there but you
should not be given the right to insult
and to taunt Jews after the death of
Jews